The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All
right, today we're
going to do some crossover
between two kinds of data
structures, memory
hierarchy data structures
and geometric data structures.
And this will be
the final lecture
in the memory hierarchy series,
so the end of cache oblivious.
So we're going to look at
two-dimensional geometric data
structure problems,
both offline and online.
So our good friend,
orthogonal 2D range searching,
which we spent a lot of
time in a few years ago,
we will come back to, and try
to get our bounds good, even
cache obliviously.
So instead of log n,
we want log base b of n
to make things interesting.
And the batch version
is where you're
given a whole bunch
of rectangles,
and a whole bunch
of points up front,
and you want to find
all the points that
live in all the rectangles.
So that's an easier
version of the problem.
We'll start with
that and then we'll
go to the usual
online version, where
you have queries coming one at
a time, rectangles coming one
at a time.
The points are pre-processed,
it will be static.
And to do the
batched, we're going
to introduce a new technique
called distribution sweep,
which is a combination of
the sweep line technique
we saw back as we
used persistence
to make sweep line thing
into a data structure thing.
But we're just going to use
the algorithmic version of that
plus a cache oblivious
sorting algorithm.
So we'll finally do
cache oblivious sorting
and optimal N/B log
base M/B / of N/B
using a particular algorithm
called lazy funnel sort, which
you can actually also use to
make another kind of cache
oblivious priority queue,
but we won't get into that.
And so by combining those two
things, we'll get a divide
and conquer technique for
geometric problems that
lets us solve the batched
thing, and then we'll
use completely
different techniques
for the online thing.
So for starters, let's finally
do cache oblivious optimal
sorting.
I'm not going to analyze this
algorithm because it's just
an algorithm, not
a data structure,
and also because the
analysis is pretty
close to the analysis
for priority queues
we did last class.
So funnel sort is
basically a merge sort.
I mentioned last time
that in external memory,
the right way to do,
or a right way to do
optimal external memory sorting
is an m over B-way merge sort.
In cache obliviously, you
don't know what m and b are,
so it's hard to do
m over B-way merge.
So instead, you basically
do a N-way merge.
Not quite N-way, I
can't afford that,
but it's going to be n to
the 1/3 way merge sort.
And the big question then
becomes, how do you do emerge?
And the answer is with a funnel.
And so the heart of the
algorithm is a funnel.
So if you have K-sorted
lists that are big,
sized K cubed, then you can
merge them in, basically,
the optimal bound.
So K-funnel, K-sorted
lists, total size K cubed.
Number of memory
transfers to merge
them is K cubed over B
times log base M/B of K
cubed over B.
There's a plus K term
and when you plug this into
an actual sorting algorithm,
you need to think about that,
but that's not a big deal.
Usually this term will dominate.
OK, so let me show
you how funnel works.
We're just going to go
through the algorithmic part
and I won't analyze the
number of memory transfers.
Maybe I'll draw this here.
So we're going to
have the inputs down
at the bottom of this funnel.
It's going to have
some data in them.
Those k inputs down
here, total size,
all these is theta K cubed.
And then at the top here,
we have our output buffer.
This is where we're
going to put the results
and this will have size K cubed.
Maybe we've already
done some work
and we've filled some of it.
OK, the question is what
do you put in this triangle
to do the merge?
And the obvious thing
is recursive triangles.
Recursion is like
the one technique
we know in cache
oblivious data structures.
So we're going to take
square root of K-funnels
and just join them together
in the obvious way.
So just like [INAUDIBLE]
layout, except--
I didn't quite leave
enough room here--
in between the
levels are buffers.
There's a buffer here
two between the nodes
of this funnel and the
nodes of this funnel.
OK, these buffers may have some
stuff in them at any moment.
OK, and the big question is
how do you set the buffer size?
This is the key step.
And the claim is each buffer,
we set to a size of K to the 3/2
because the number of buffers
is about square root of K
because there's one per
leaf of this funnel.
And a K-funnel has K inputs,
so a root K funnel is going
to have root K inputs here.
And so the total size
of all the buffers
is K squared, which
is not too big.
I'm not going to go
through the recurrence,
but if you add up the
total size of this thing,
it is linear size in
the output, K cubed.
I think also if you don't count
the output buffer, it's linear
and K squared.
If I recall correctly.
We're not too concerned with
that here, just overall.
Once we have
K-funnels, funnel sort
is just going to be N to the
1/3 way merge sort with an N
to the 1/3 funnel as the merger.
We can only up to n the 1/3
because of this cubic thing.
We can only merge--
if we want the sorting bound
N/B log base M/B of N/B
we can only afford K
being up to n to the 1/3.
So that's the biggest we can do.
So it's a recursive algorithm
where each of the merging steps
is this recursive
data structure.
Now, this is really
just about layout.
I haven't told you what the
actual algorithm is yet,
but it's a recursive layout.
You store the entire
upper triangle,
then each of the triangles,
somewhere you put the buffers.
It doesn't really
matter where the buffers
are as long as each
triangle is stored.
As a consecutive array
of memory, we'll be OK.
And now let me tell you
about the actual algorithm
to do this.
It's a very simple
lazy algorithm.
So there's a whole
bunch of buffers.
If you want to do this merge,
really what you'd like to do
is fill this output buffer.
So you call this subroutine
called fill on the output
buffer and say, I would like
to fill this entire buffer
with elements.
Precondition, if you're going to
do a fill, right now the buffer
is empty, and then at
the end of the fill
you'd like this to
be completely full.
And how do you do it?
Well, if you look
at any buffer--
partially filled, whatever--
and you look right below it,
there's a node in this tree.
You recurse all the way down.
In the end, this is just a
binary tree with buffers in it.
So it's going to be there's a
buffer, then there's a node,
then there's two children,
each of which is a buffer,
and then there's
a node below that.
OK, so how do I fill this thing?
I just read the first
item, the beginning,
the smallest item for each
of these, compare them.
Whichever smaller,
I stick at here.
It's just a regular binary
merge which is kind of cool.
You've got two arrays.
You want to merge them.
Stick the results here.
So that's how we do fill.
Binary merge of the two children
buffers until we're full.
But there's one thing
that can happen,
which is that one of the
child buffers might empty.
What do we do then?
Recursively fill it.
That's the algorithm.
Very simple.
The obvious lazy thing to do.
Do a binary merge.
This is going to be nice
because it's like two scans,
until one of these guys empties,
and then you pause this merge,
and then say OK, I'm going to
fill this entire buffer, which
will recursively do stuff
until it's completely full
or I run out of input elements,
whichever comes first,
and then resume this merge.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Aren't there more
than two child buffers?
ERIK DEMAINE: Should only
be two children buffers.
The question is, are
there more than two?
This recursion of the root
k and root k child triangles
of size root k is
exactly the recursion
we did on a binary tree.
I didn't say, but underlying
this is a binary tree.
The only difference between
this and a [INAUDIBLE] layout
is we're adding these buffers.
I intended to draw
this as binary.
It's a little hard to tell
because I didn't draw the base
case, but it is indeed a
binary tree in the end.
OK, other questions?
So that's the algorithm
and as I said,
I'm not going to analyze it, but
it's the same kind of analysis.
You look at the threshold
where things fit in cache
or don't and argue accordingly.
It's pretty hand-wavy.
What I want to get
to is how we use
this to solve more interesting
problems than sorting.
Sorting is a little bit boring.
So let's go to batched
orthogonal range searching.
And in general, this technique
called distribution sweep.
The idea with distribution
sweep is that not only can we
use this cool funnel
sort algorithm to sort,
but we can think of
it as doing a divide
and conquer on the key value.
And in this case, we
have two coordinates.
We're going to use
the divide and conquer
on one of the coordinates.
And where we have
some flexibility
is in this binary merge step.
We're doing this binary
merge, and normally it's
just you take the min, you spit
it out here, you take the min,
you spit it out here.
That's the min of one
particular coordinate.
Now you've got to deal with
some auxiliary information
about the other coordinates.
So in general, you're
merging two sorted things.
If there's other
geometric information,
you can try to preserve
it during the merge.
As long as you can do that, this
is the conqueror part or that
combine step of
divide and conquer.
You can do a lot.
There's a powerful
technique, it turns out.
It's by Brodal and Fagerberg.
It's in their early
days of cache oblivious.
It was the first
geometric paper.
Fine, so replace or say
augment the binary merge, which
is, in the end, the only
part of the algorithm
other than the recursion.
So it's the only thing
you need to do to maintain
auxiliary information.
That's the generic idea
of distribution sweep.
And distribution
sweep has been applied
to solve lots of
different problems.
Batched orthogonal range
queries is one of them.
Generally, you've got a
bunch of orthogonal segments,
rectangles, points, and you want
to compute how they intersect.
Those sorts of problems
that can be solved here.
Also weird things like I
give you a bunch of points
and I want to know
for every point what's
its nearest neighbor.
In Euclidean sense,
that can be solved.
But I like orthogonal
range searching
because it's the closest to
our data structure problem
and that's a problem we've seen.
So the actual batched
orthogonal range searching
is your given N points,
and N rectangles,
and you want to know which
points are in which rectangles.
That's the general problem.
So normally, we're
given the points first,
and then we're given the
rectangles one at a time.
That's what we've
solved in the past.
That's what we will solve later.
That's the online version.
The batched version
is I give you
a whole bunch of queries
I want to simultaneously
and we're going to achieve
the sorting bound N/B log base
M/B of N/B plus the size
of the output over B.
And this is
generally the optimal
bound you could hope for.
It's not obvious
you need the log,
but I think for most
problems in external memory
you need this log.
It's hard to beat
the sorting bound,
and then once you pay
this is the optimal linear time
to just write down the output.
Now, this problem can be solved.
Give me all the point
rectangle pairs that result.
I'm not going to
solve it here exactly.
We're going to solve a
slightly different version,
or in general--
whatever.
Let me tell you about another
version of this problem, which
is a little bit easier.
Then I'll sketch how
you solve that problem.
So remember, we've talked
about range reporting
and also range
counting, which is you
just want to know the
number of answers.
Here's something in between.
You want to know
for every point,
how many rectangles contain it?
And particularly,
this will tell you
for each point, does
it appear in any
of the rectangles in the set?
It will tell you how
many and this is actually
necessary as a first
step because one
of the hard parts in solving
these kinds of problems
or reporting problems, is
that the output could be big.
We know that's always an issue,
but with cache oblivious,
it's a big issue, literally,
because space is important.
You can't afford to
put space anywhere.
If these buffers have to
get much bigger in order
to store those
answers, then life
is kind of tough because
then this data structure
gets too big, and then my
analysis goes out the window
because things that
used to fit in cache,
no longer fit in cache.
The analysis I didn't show you.
So it's an issue.
So the first step
of this algorithm
is to first figure out
how big those buffers have
to be so that we don't have
to allocate them too large.
And to do that, we
need to basically count
how many answers there are,
and this is what we'll do.
To compute these values,
the answers aren't very big.
These answers are just
single numbers per point,
so it's no big deal.
OK, so here's what we do.
Sort the points and the
corners of the rectangles
by x-coordinate using
lazy final sort.
Nothing fancy here.
No augmentation,
regular old sort.
Then-- this will
be useful later--
then we're going to
divide and conquer
on y via a distribution sweep.
And here, our binary merger
is going to be an upward sweep
line algorithm.
So let's talk about that
sweep line algorithm.
We presorted our points by x.
If you think about the merging
step, what this means--
it's confusing.
We're trying to sort by y,
we were in a certain sense,
but we're always going to be
sorted by x because we did that
up front.
So the picture is going
to be something like this.
We're in a slab.
There's going to
be the left slab.
So here's the binary merger.
Here's the L points
and the R points.
The L points are going to be
in a particular x interval.
The R points are going to
be in an adjacent x interval
corresponding to
this tree picture.
And then we have these points,
which they overlap and why?
Because the whole point is
we're trying to merge by y.
OK, we also have
some rectangles,
and their corners are
what we have represented.
I probably should
have used colors here.
Something like this.
So we're given,
essentially-- we have
whatever we want on the
points and corners in here.
We have whatever we
want in the points
and corners in this slab.
Let me add a little
bit of color.
These lines.
And now we want to merge these
two things and merging here
is all about counting how many
rectangles contain each point.
Now, we already know how
many points over here
are contained in rectangles
that are over here.
So we've presumably
already found
that this point lies
in this rectangle.
We've already found--
I guess there's no points here.
We've already found
that this point
is contained in this rectangle.
OK, because these corners were
in this slab, and so let's say
every corner knows
the entire rectangle.
So when you were processing
R, you saw these corners,
you saw this point.
Somehow you figured that out.
What we're missing are things
like this rectangle, where
none of the corners
are inside R.
So R knew nothing
about this rectangle,
and yet it has points
that are contained in it.
Similarly, there are these
rectangles that completely
span L, and so therefore none
of the corners are inside L.
But we need to know that
these points are in there.
Those are the only things that
will be missing at this level.
There might be other
rectangles that completely
span L and R. Those will be
discovered at higher levels,
now here.
It's a little bit awkward to
check if this will actually
find everything, but it will.
So to figure this out, when
we're merging L and R--
see, L knows about
this rectangle
because it sees these points.
We want to keep track
as we sweep upwards.
We want to realize that these
points are in a big rectangle
here, whereas they
weren't discovered in L,
and they weren't
discovered in R.
To do that, we maintain a number
as-- we have a horizontal line,
we're sweeping up.
We want to maintain the
number of active rectangles.
Active means that it's currently
being sliced by the sweep line.
That have left corners
in L and completely
span R. So that's these guys.
So that's easy to do.
We're merging these points.
So that each of them
has been sorted by y.
Now we're doing
a merge, so we're
considering all the
corners, and all the points,
and increasing the y-coordinate
as we do that binary merge.
So whenever we visit a left
corner of a rectangle--
a lower left corner-- we
say oh, does this rectangle
go all the way across?
This one does not.
By the time we get to here, this
one goes all the way cross R,
and so we increment CL.
And when we get to the upper
left corner, we decrement CL.
Say oh, that rectangle's over.
So it's very easy
to do constant time,
but it's only going
to be 1/B memory
transfers per one of
these because it's
a nice, cheap merge.
And then symmetrically,
we do CR.
It's the number of
active rectangles
with the right
corners in R that span
L. So that's this guy, CR,
I guess, this guy is CL.
In general, there might be a
lot of them, so you count them.
And then the only
thing we need to do
is whenever we
encounter a point as
opposed to a corner,
because we're storing them
all together, we add--
I got this right--
CR to it's counter.
We want to know how many
rectangles contain that point.
And so for example,
when we see this point,
and CR is currently one, then
we know that this point appeared
in some rectangle
that spanned L.
So we increment
this points counter.
Similarly, when we see these
points, CL is positive,
so we increment these guys
counters by whatever CL is.
So this is a symmetric
version in R when we add CL.
Probably should have called
them the other names,
but anyway, CL,
CR, doesn't matter.
CLRS.
Question?
AUDIENCE: The bottom
is the x-axis, right?
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is the x-axis, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are we dividing
and conquering on x?
ERIK DEMAINE: It does look like
we're dividing and conquering
on x, I think you're right.
Sorry.
For some reason I
thought it was y.
You're right.
So it's a funny thing.
We're pre-sorting by x,
which is what's getting us--
thank you.
That's much clearer now.
In my mind I was like
there's something weird here.
We're presorting on
x and then we're just
sticking these guys down here.
So evenly dividing
them into lists.
Or, I guess actually, we're
doing our funnel sort,
the merge sort.
Things have already
been sorted by x,
but now we're merge
sorting again,
and this time when we merge, we
carry along this information.
So they're both in terms of
x, which is kind of funny.
Is there another question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is it
important that we do
the upward sweep [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: The upward sweep.
Yeah, we have to do the
points in order by y.
AUDIENCE: So do we
want to just sort
by y, and then [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah,
so confused now.
AUDIENCE: Because in the
notes, it said x and then y.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, I know
in the notes it says y.
It used to say x.
I believe, we're dividing
and conquering on x,
but we're sorting by y,
and that's the confusion.
I'll double check
this, but in order
for this sweep to work-- so
it's like you first sort by x.
You
We are in some sense
doing divide and conquer
by x because we
did this sort by x.
But the merge short is on y.
It makes more sense.
If you're already
in x order, sorting
isn't going to learn you much.
It isn't going to
teach you much.
So first you sort by x.
Things are nicely ordered by x.
So we get these nice horizontal
slabs in the decomposition,
but now when we merge--
Now we're going to sort by y.
So we're going to reorder
the points and that's
what lets us do the sweep.
And we are, in the end, merging
all these points together
in y order.
And as we do it, then
we get the information
we want about
rectangles and points.
OK, this is why I wanted
this to be both x and y.
But really, the divide and
conquer is happening on x,
but we are doing
a merge sort on y.
Finally clear.
Thanks for helping me.
This is a new lecturers,
as you may have guessed,
so still working out some kinks.
I really wanted to
introduce this lecture
because the next thing
we're going to cover,
which is a way to do orthogonal
2D range search and cache
obviously, is super cool.
It's like one of the
craziest things there is.
At least in the cache
oblivious world.
Any other questions before--
Oh, I should say a little
bit more about this.
We've now solved this first
step, which is figuring out
the output size.
Counting for each point how
many rectangles contain it,
which is an interesting
problem by itself.
That's the range
counting problem.
You can also use it to
figure out, at this level,
at this merging step, how many
things will be output here?
How many new outputs are there?
How many points in
rectangles are there?
It's essentially just the
sum of all those things.
So you can count the
number of outputs per merge
and so then there's a natural
strategy, which is you
build a new funnel structure
where these buffers
have the right size.
You've pre-computed what
all sizes need to be.
At every merge you
know how many things
are going to get spit out here.
So you could allocate that
much space and that will
be a kind of decent merge sort.
Because I haven't
done the analysis,
it's hard to get into
detail about this.
But it will not be
optimal, unfortunately.
To actually make
it work, you end up
having to take this
tree, carving it
into subtrees of linear size.
So normally, the whole
thing is linear size.
Everything's fine.
And where the analysis
breaks, essentially,
is if you have a giant buffer
because one of the outputs--
potentially, the output
size here is quadratic.
And so the overall thing
might be super linear.
And so when you have a super
linear buffer or a bunch
of very large buffers
that sum to linear size,
you essentially need to
carve that tree, which
you do by recursive
carving of the tree.
So that each of the
trees has linear size.
Then you apply the analysis to
each of the trees separately.
You store them
consecutively, separately.
Each of them has good
optimal running time
and then the combination does.
That's the hand-wavy
version of how
to do actual range reporting
with end points and end
rectangles.
If you're interested in the
details, read the paper.
It's just a little bit
messy and especially when
you don't know the analysis.
I want to move on to
online orthogonal 2D
range searching because it's
the hardest and coolest of them
all.
Unless there are more questions.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So you do the
range counting [INAUDIBLE]
in detail, and [INAUDIBLE]
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
ERIK DEMAINE: Exactly.
At this point, if you
believe in funnel sort,
you should believe that
range counting is easy to do,
and I've just hand waved
the range reporting part.
Are you scribing?
Is that why you ask?
That's where we stand.
The next thing we're going to
do is regular range reporting,
regular online stuff.
So this is orthogonal
2D range search.
And we spent a
couple of lectures
on 2D and 3D range search.
All this crazy stuff with
fractional cascading,
and so on, and the
layered range trees.
We're going to use some of those
techniques that we built there,
and in particular,
you may recall
there was this idea that if
we have a bunch of points,
regular 2D range searching
is I give you a rectangle,
give me all the points
in the rectangle.
Fine.
Our goal is to achieve log base
B of N plus output size over B.
That's the new optimal bound.
This is how long it takes to
do a regular search in one
dimension.
So if you have output
size whatever--
and we'll probably be
able to do range counting,
but I won't worry about it here.
We'll just think
about range reporting.
If there's this
many points, we'll
output them all in
that much over B.
This is what we call a
regular range search,
but I'm going to distinguish it
and call it a four sided range
search because a
rectangle has four sides.
But you could think
of the other versions
and we actually did this when
we were doing the 3-D problem.
So if these are two
rays and an edge,
this you might call a
three sided rectangle,
and you can go all the
way down to two sides.
Hard to go down to one side.
Here's a two sided rectangle,
it just has two rays.
OK, as you might expect,
this is easier than that.
And if I recall, in 3-D we ended
up doing this thing in linear
space with this fancy--
first you do a search
on the left coordinate
and then you just walk.
We'd subdivided with
fractional cascading
so that every face
had constant size,
and so you could
just walk, and each
step you'd report a new point.
If you may recall for this
kind of two sided thing.
First, you would
search for this,
and then you would basically
just follow this line until you
found this point, this corner.
This we could achieve in a
linear space, logarithmic time.
This one we needed
N log N space.
Actually, the best known is
N log N divided by log log N.
But we could N log
N using range trees.
And we got down to
log N time using--
log N query time and log N
space using layered range trees.
That was the internal
memory regular algorithms.
AUDIENCE: Aren't you
missing an M/B though?
ERIK DEMAINE: Am
I missing an M/B?
No, this is log base B of N,
not log base M/B of N. Yeah,
it's good to ask.
When we're sorting this kind
of thing, we get log base M/B,
but when you're searching,
the best you can do
is log base B. We
actually proved
a lower bound about this in the
first memory hierarchy lecture.
Because this is online,
you read it in a block.
You can only learn where
you fit among B items.
And so the best you
can hope to achieve
is log base B of N for
search in one dimension.
So this is a lower
bound for search.
When you're doing
batch operations,
then you can hope to
achieve this stuff, which
is a lot faster.
Then it's like 1/B times
log base M/B of M/B.
OK, so in a certain
sense, this is
slower than the
batched operations,
but it's more online.
So it's a trade-off.
So for all these problems we
can achieve log base B of N
plus [? out ?] over B.
The issue is with space.
Maybe I'll do sort of regular
RAM algorithms versus cache
oblivious.
So we've got two sided,
three sided, four sided.
And for two sided, I believe
these are the right answers.
Log N over log log N. But we
haven't actually seen this one.
And cache oblivious,
here's what we can do.
This is with optimal query
times and this is all static.
OK, and if there's time,
I'll cover all of these.
So they're not perfect.
These two were off by a
log factor, but not bad.
Pretty good orthogonal
2D range queries.
And really, the coolest
one is this one.
This one blows my mind
every time I see it.
So let's do it.
We'll start with two
sided and then we
have existing
techniques once you
have two sided to
add on more sides,
you may recall from the 3D
range searching lecture.
So we're going to
use those techniques
and refine them a little bit
to get that log log factor.
But you may recall way back
when, at lecture six or so,
that we had a technique.
Once it was two
sided, every time
we added a log factor in space,
we could add another side.
The hard part was getting
up the number of dimensions.
Then the easy part was turning
half infinite intervals
into regular intervals.
So once we have this, it's easy
to add a log, add another log.
With a bit of sophistication,
we can save a log log factor.
OK, but let's do two sided.
This will be the
bulk of the lecture.
This is a paper by [? Harga ?]
and [? Zey ?] in 2006.
All right, so we want to do--
I'm going to assume that
they are this kind of quarter
plain query.
So less than or
equal to x, less than
or equal to some y-coordinate.
We want to know all the
points in that quarter plane.
So here's what
we're going to do.
It's all static.
We're going to have a
Van Emde Boas layout.
So a binary tree on
the y-coordinate.
So this just stores all
the points sorted by y.
So if you want to do this query,
use search for that value of y,
then each of these positions
in between two keys in here
has a pointer to an array.
The array is not sorted by x
or y, it's a very weird thing.
And then here's the
algorithm you follow.
You follow this pointer, you
go here, you walk to the right
until you find a point whose
x-coordinate is too big.
It's bigger than x.
I should probably
call this x2, y2.
So first you search for a y2
here, in this thing keyed by y.
Follow the pointer.
You look at all the points that
have x-coordinate less than
or equal to x2.
Those are the ones you want.
Once you find a point whose
x-coordinate is bigger than x2,
you stop, and then you
report these points.
It's not quite so simple
because some of these points
might be duplicates.
You have to remove duplicates.
That is your answer.
To me, this is an insane idea.
I would never
imagine this to work.
But the claim is you can make
this array have linear size.
That's the hard part.
Make this, the amount of stuff
that you have to traverse here,
be linear in out in the number
of points that are actually
in this range.
You are going to do a little
bit more work because there
are duplicates in here, but only
a constant factor of more work.
And yet somehow, you've taken
this two dimensional problem
and squashed it onto a line.
You did one search at
the beginning, which
costs you log base B of N,
then you do this linear scan,
and you get the right
answer, magically.
I don't know how they thought
this would be possible,
but magically, it turns
out it is possible.
It was kind of a breakthrough
in cache oblivious
range searching.
It was known how to do this for
external memory a lot easier.
For example, you can
do it with persistence,
but this is a much cooler way
to do two sided range queries.
All right, so I've explained
the query algorithm.
The big thing I
haven't explained
is how to build this array.
Maybe I'll write
down the things we
need to prove as well
before we get there,
so you can think
about them as we're
writing down the algorithm.
First claim is that this
algorithm, which just decides
to stop whenever it gets an
x-coordinate that is too big,
actually finds the right answer.
It Finds all points in the
range that we care about.
The second thing is that the
number of scanned points,
the length of that step here,
is order the size of the output.
The number of actual
output points.
We don't waste time
doing the scan.
And the other thing is that the
array has size order N. That's
the biggest surprise to me.
So those are the
three things we need
to prove about the algorithm,
which I will now tell you.
OK, before I can define
how this array works,
I need to define a
concept called density.
If we look at a query, there's
two things that could happen.
The good thing for
us would be if--
get this right.
The number of points in
lesser or equal to x star
is at most, alpha times the
number of points in the answer.
OK, star means no
restriction on y.
Minus infinity to infinity.
This would be good for
us because it says--
ultimately what we're trying
to do here is do a scan in x.
It's the right thing to do here.
Then for this
particular y-coordinate,
we could just basically start
at the beginning of the array,
start scanning, and just
report all the points
that are actually in our range.
Sorry, I need to also
potentially throw away
points that are not low enough.
So the answer is
contained in here.
I should say to throw
away duplicates,
you have to throw away points
that are not in the range
lesser or equal to x,
comma lesser or equal to y.
Still, we claim the
number of scan points
is proportional to
the output size.
That's what we need.
So if this held for every
query, we'd be happy.
Just start at the
beginning, scan,
and as long as this
alpha is some constant--
it's going to be a
constant bigger than 1,
then the number of points in
the answer is proportional--
sorry, the number of
points we had to scan
through is proportional to the
number of points in the answer,
and so we're done.
So this is the easy case.
We need to distinguish
it, otherwise we
call this range query
sparse, and those
are the interesting cases.
So nothing deep
here, but we're going
to use this concept a lot.
OK, so we're going
to actually try
to solve this problem twice.
The first try isn't going
to be quite successful,
but it gets a lot
of the right ideas.
So I'm going to let S0 be
all the points sorted by x.
It's going to be sorted by x.
I put things down here.
And just to give you an
idea of where we're going,
the array we're
imagining here is first
we write down all
the points, then
we'll write down some subset
of the points, S1, then
some subset of that subset,
and so on until we get down
to a constant size structure.
OK, first we write
down all the points.
Why?
Because for dense queries,
that's what we want.
We want all the points
just sitting there.
So then you can just read
through all the points
and dense queries will be happy.
So if we detect a y-coordinate
where the queries going to be
dense--
I don't know how we detect that.
Let's not worry
about it right now--
then you could just
look through S0.
That's fine.
But some queries are
going to be sparse,
and for that we're going
to use S1, S2, and so on.
The intuition is the following.
If in your query,
the y-coordinate
is very large,
like say infinity,
then your query is
guaranteed to be dense.
It doesn't matter what x is.
And in general, if
y is near the top,
like it's at the top most
point, or maybe the next of top
most point, or maybe a
little bit farther down,
it depends on the point
set, then a lot of queries
are going to be dense.
So that's good news.
Let's consider the first time
when there's a sparse query.
So we're going to let yi be the
largest y-coordinate where some
query, some x-coordinate--
that y-coordinate.
This is going to be less than
or equal to x, comma less than
or equal to yi--
is sparse in Si minus 1.
OK, so initially we
have S0, all points.
y1 is the largest y
co-ordinate where there's--
so we work our way
down until there's
some sparse query in S0.
That's yi.
So then we just
filter, based on that.
So throw away all
the points above yi.
So we're going to
say take Si minus 1,
intersect it with the
range query, star less than
or equal to yi.
OK, so the picture is
we have some point set.
Up here, every possible
query along this line
is going to be dense
because everything
to the left of the x-coordinate
will be in the output.
At some point, we're going
to decide this is too scary.
There's a query
here, maybe this one,
or maybe it's this
query that's sparse.
And so we say OK, throw
away these points.
Redo the data structure
from here down,
ignoring all these
points, repeat,
and write down these things.
So the idea is that if you
look at a particular query,
it will be dense in
one of these Si's.
And you can tell that just
according to your y-coordinate.
Because you said oh, well, if
you're up here in y-coordinate,
you're guaranteed safe.
So just do that
search and you're OK.
In general, we
continue this process
until we get to some Si
that has constant size.
At that point, we're
done, and then we
can afford to look
through all the points.
Unfortunately, this is
not a very good strategy,
but it's the first cut, and
it's close to what works.
Here's a problem with it.
Suppose you have this point set.
OK, what happens is you start at
the top, everything looks fine.
At some point you decide
there's a query here, namely
this one, which has
an empty answer,
and yet there are points to
the left of this x-coordinate.
So that's bad because
it's very hard
to get within a
constant factor of zero.
So pretty much immediately
you've got to draw a line here
and say OK, S0 is all
points, S1 is these points,
S2 is going to be these points.
In general, there's
suffixes of the points,
and so the total space
will be quadratic.
So the first two
properties will be correct
because you're just looking
in S0, or S1, or whatever.
Everything looks
fine, but your right
does not have linear size.
So no good.
First try, failed.
Second time's the charm.
You need a little
more sophistication
in how we do this partitioning,
how we build our array,
and we'll get it.
I didn't read this before.
This one line that says
maximize common suffix.
I have no idea what
this means, but maybe it
will mean something by the end.
Let's see.
OK, this is the part I read.
So xi is going to be--
so we had a yi That's going
to be the same as before.
This is why I did
the first attempt.
This definition
remains the same.
So largest y where we have some
sparse query in Si minus 1.
I want to look at what
that x-coordinate is.
It's just that here it
says there's some x.
What is that x?
Let's just look at the maximum
possible x that it could be.
This will turn out
to be really useful.
The maximum x-coordinate where
less than or equal to xi,
comma less than or
equal to yi is sparse--
and Si minus 1.
OK, we know there's
something we can put
in here that makes yi sparse.
So look at the largest
possible such x.
So that means any query--
so we have this new point.
It's not an actual
point in our problem,
but it's a query, xi, yi.
And it's dense, oh
sorry, it's sparse.
It's bad.
We know that any query
up here is dense.
That was the definition of yi.
And now we also know that
any query over here, I guess,
that's saying a lot.
But these queries
are also dense.
Because again, if you're
far enough to the right,
that's going to be
basically everything.
So let's get rid
of that as well.
And this is a problem,
queries over here
are also potentially a problem.
We don't know.
It doesn't seem like much,
but it will be enough.
We're going to
redefine Si as well.
So here's the fun part.
If we have some
Si minus 1, we're
going to define a
new thing, which
is Pi minus 1, which is this.
This is a funny thing, but it
is this part of the point set.
This is Pi minus 1.
So the points we care
about are kind of here,
but let's just take
everything to the left
of this x-coordinate.
Why not?
It's a thing.
That is Pi minus 1.
So Si minus 1 is
everything in this picture.
First, let's restrict
to x, then the next step
is we're going to restrict to y.
But it's in a funny way.
This is the Si, the next s set.
Take the previous set
and we intersect it
with a funny thing.
It's harder to
write algebraically
than it is to draw the picture.
So it's intersected with a
union, which is basically--
dare I draw it on
the same picture?
Where's my red?
It's going to be less
than or equal to y.
This thing is going to be Si.
We'll see why,
eventually, this works.
I still don't know what
maximize common suffix means,
but we'll get there.
So we're looking at the
points below the line.
That's what we did before.
We used to say Si is just the
intersection with less than
or equal to yi.
But things are just
a little bit messier
because of this restriction.
Do I really not have a P here?
OK, here's the difference.
The reason we have to go
through this business.
The array that we're going
to store is not the Si's.
Si's are still too
big, potentially.
What we're going to
store are the Pi's.
Pi minus 1.
And then in the end,
we're in a store Si.
Si, again, has constant size.
The final Si has constants size.
I probably should have
used a different letter, Sk
or whatever.
We keep doing this
until we get down
to something constant
sized, then we store it.
That's the easy case.
Until then, we just store
the Pi's, because really, we
know that all the queries up
here and over here are OK.
They're nice and dense.
We sort of only care about the
points to the left of the line.
OK, but essentially, the
Si has to pick up the slack
and we have to include
these points in the next Si.
Whereas, before, we did not.
Before we just took
things below the line.
Now we have to take things
that are below the line
or to the right of
the vertical line.
This is essentially
necessary for correctness.
So we kind of win
some, we lose some.
But it turns out all is well.
So I know this is weird, but
let's jump to the analysis.
These claims, in particular,
that the array has linear size.
Let's think about that and it
will become clear why the heck
we've made these choices.
Unless you have
a question first.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any relationship
between the Si here and
the Si on the first try?
ERIK DEMAINE: No,
this definition of Si
is no longer in effect.
S0 is correct, and all the
Si's are still sorted by x.
We're no longer doing this.
Instead of this rule,
we're doing this rule.
This part is the same, but we
have this extra union, which
contradicts the previous rule.
So the yi definition
is the same.
Sorry, it's a little weird.
xi is new, Pi is
new, and Si is new.
At this point, it's this
algebraic weird thing.
Here's the cool thing.
For the space
bound, the claim is
Pi minus 1 intersect Si
is less than or equal to 1
over alpha times Pi minus 1.
This is hard to even
interpret what it means,
but it's good news.
So remember, alpha is
a number bigger than 1.
It's what we use in the
definition of density,
and you could set this parameter
to whatever you want, say 2.
So then we're going to get that
this thing, whatever it is,
is at most half the size
of the previous one.
I claim this is good news.
I claim it means that these Pi's
essentially are geometrically
decreasing in size,
which is how we get--
that's not quite right, but this
will give us a charging scheme.
which will prove that the
whole thing has linear size.
First, why is this true?
It could really only be true
for sparsity from the alpha.
Right, so we said
oh, density is good.
If we have dense,
there's nothing to do.
Just put the points in
x order, we're done.
Sparse is bad.
But actually, sparse
tells us something.
It tells us there
are a lot of points
that are not in the answer.
So we're looking at
this query, xi yi.
And we'd like to just say oh,
start at negative infinity,
and just take all the
points up to here.
If we're dense, that is
within a constant factor
of the number of points that are
actually in the answer, which
is down here.
If we're sparse, that means
there are a lot of points
up here.
Most of the points have to be
up here in order to be sparse.
And that's actually
what this is saying
if you expand the definitions.
So Pi minus 1, that was
all the stuff to the left.
So that's this thing.
This is what we would get
if we just did a linear scan
from left to right.
Versus we're
considering the points
in Pi minus 1, which
just restricts to x,
and then we're looking at Si.
Si does this business.
But if we restrict
to the Si points that
are to the left of the line--
so we're looking
at, basically, this
left portion, which was this
white rectangle, intersected
with this funny red rectangle,
which was kind of awkward--
the intersection is just this.
That's the answer for
this query, xi yi.
OK, so this is the size
of the answer for xi yi.
And this was the
number of points
in less than or
equal to xi star.
We wanted to just do a
linear scan like this.
But this is the correct
answer and because we
know that this point
is sparse-- that was
the definition of xi and yi, it
was the maximum sparse point.
So it's a sparse
point, therefore
we know that this does not hold.
So the number of points less
than or equal to x comma star
is greater than alpha
times the number
of points in the correct range.
And if I got it right,
that should be this.
You could put alpha over
here without the one over
and I guess this is
strictly greater.
No big deal.
So that's the
definition of sparsity.
So this is the
cool thing we know.
Now, we're going to use--
this is now a
numbered less than 1.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So for Pi
minus 1, we add them
as the number of points
less than xi star.
But for example--
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes, that's
the definition here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like Pi, you
don't have that block in
the top left corner, right?
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
After we restrict
to Si, yeah, we've
thrown away all of these points.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So if you take the next
Pi, it's not necessarily
going to be the points
less than or equal to xi--
ERIK DEMAINE: It's true.
When I say points, I
don't mean all points.
I mean points in Si minus 1.
I'm dropping that
because it gets
awkward to keep talking about.
So that's a correctness
issue, essentially.
You have to argue that we
can throw away these points
and it's safe.
Once we do, then you could
just ignore their existence.
You can ignore their
existence because you already
solved all the
dense queries, which
are over here, or over here,
which involve those points.
And so we now know
that we're only
going to be doing
queries from here down.
Otherwise, you look at P0.
So forget about those.
Forget about those points.
Now you're going to be searching
in one of these structures.
So you can forget about
all the points over here.
So that's that argument.
Once you've restricted
to Si minus 1
and you don't have to
look at any other points,
among those points,
this is going
to be all the points
less than or equal to xi.
But that's how we were
defining bar sparse.
We said sparse in Si minus 1.
So it's among those
points we have sparsity.
So this is the definition
of what we have.
OK, the claim is
it's a good thing.
Here's the charging scheme.
So this is by sparsity.
So I'm going to charge storing
Pi minus 1 to Pi minus 1
minus Si.
This algebra, I have to
interpret every single time,
but that's fine.
Let's look at the picture.
OK, Pi minus 1 remember, was
this white rectangle over here.
Everything to the
left of the line.
We have to store Pi.
We want that the sum of the
sizes of the Pi's is good.
And so here's my
charging scheme.
We have to store Pi minus 1.
I'm going to charge
it to these points.
What are those points?
Those are the points that are
inside the white rectangle,
but outside the red L-shape.
So that's these points.
This is Pi minus 1 minus Si.
Those are the points
that I'm throwing away.
That's good.
So if I charge them now, I will
never charge them in the future
because I just threw them away.
They are not in the next Si.
Each point overall in the point
set only gets charged once.
OK, how much does
it get charged?
How do these things relate
to each other in size?
That's where we use this thing.
It gets confusing to think about
intersection versus difference,
but the point is if we look
at the Pi minus ones that are
in Si, that's a small fraction.
Think of alpha as 100.
So then the Pi minus 1-- so this
part down here that's in Si,
this is only 1/100 of the
whole white rectangle.
So that means this part
is 99/100 of the Pi.
So if we charged the storing
of the entire rectangle
to these guys, we're only
losing a very small factor
like 100/99 or something.
It isn't actually exactly
100/99, I believe.
I worked it out and
the factor of charging,
assuming I did it
correctly, is 1 over 1
minus 1 over alpha,
which works out
to alpha over alpha minus 1.
It doesn't really matter, but
the point is it's constant.
I think that's easy to believe.
Maybe it's actually easiest to
think about when alpha is 2.
At most, half the
points are here.
At least, half the
And so we're charging
storing the entire point set
to these points, which will
never get charged again.
So we're only charging
with a factor of two.
That's all we need,
a constant factor.
OK, therefore, this
thing has linear size.
That's the cool thing.
We get more though.
We also get the
query bound we want.
Let's think about
the query bound.
This is fun.
Think about where the query is.
It used to be over here.
We do a search in S0,
or we do a search in S1,
or we do a search in S2.
We'd never look at multiple Si's
because there'd be no point.
Either S0 was dense, and
we're fine, just do it.
Or you have to jump to
S1, skip some guys up top,
do the search in there.
Fine.
We no longer have that luxury
over here because we're using
Pi's instead of Si's.
So it actually may be
the search starts in P1,
but then has to go through
P2, and has to go through P3.
But it's OK because
the farther we
go right, we have this sparsity
condition that tells us
basically the points
we're looking at are--
the number of points
we're looking at
are getting smaller and smaller.
So I'll wave my hands
a little bit here,
but the claim is it's
a geometric series.
This needs a formal proof, but
we won't go through it here.
Decreasing-- so this
is the query bound.
The number of scanned
points is order output size.
So you have to check that no
matter where you start in Pi--
that's the little
bit tricky part.
We're not looking at all of Pi.
We're looking at
some of Pi and then
we're going to the
right from there.
Actually, is that true?
Maybe we always
look at all of Pi.
Let me think about this.
I think we do, actually.
Sorry.
That's what we did before.
We basically figure out
where we are in y-coordinate.
That was the overall structure.
We had a Van Emde
Boas search tree on y.
So all we know at this point is
the y-coordinate of our search.
And so we use that to
determine which of the Pi's we
go to, based on where the
yi becomes no longer dense.
And then we're going to have to
search through that entire Pi
and potentially more
of them because this
is no longer an Si.
It's just doing the
things to the left.
And so if we're lucky,
the Pi we're looking at,
or the query we're doing, is
not to the right of this point.
OK, maybe it's right here.
That would be great.
Then all our answers are done.
If our query is here, that
would have been dense,
so we would have done
it at an earlier stage.
Our query might be
down here though.
When the query's down here, we
need to report on these points.
Then we're going
to have to do more
and that's going
to be Pi plus 1.
So we'll do more and
more Pi's until we
get to our actual query here.
But in any case, the claim
is that this is geometrically
decreasing by the
same charging scheme.
OK, that's two out
of the three claims.
There's one more, which
is closely related.
It's still about
the query problem.
What we haven't shown is that
we actually find all the points.
This is what you might
call correctness.
To prove this, what
we need to say--
what we claim is that
after you do the P1's--
and now you do the P2's.
Well, I'll tell you.
The claim is that you visited
some x-coordinates here.
The Pi's were all the things
up to some x-coordinate.
Claim that the very
next point in here,
in P2, has a smaller
x-coordinate than what you just
did.
I think that should be clear
because presumably there
are some points in here, and
so the very next Pi, it's
restricted within
this red thing,
but it's going to be up
to some x-coordinate.
So you're basically
starting over.
Every time you go to the Pi's,
you're starting over in x.
Go back to minus infinity in x.
So the idea is the picture
will look something like this.
You start at minus infinity,
you read some points.
At some point, you
run out of the Pi's.
Then you start over again,
you read some smaller set
of the points.
Maybe you get a little farther.
You start over again,
read a little farther.
At some point, you're going
to reach your threshold x.
That's when you stop.
So that's correctness.
I feel like I need
another sentence there.
Once your Pi encompasses
your x range,
that's going to
have your answer.
Then you're done.
So that's this moment.
And so the only worry is that
an early Pi, basically, or maybe
the next Pi does
this, and then we
do this or something like this.
That never happens basically
because you're always
resetting x range.
And so your x will always
start over to something
less than what you had.
And so the
termination condition,
which I probably didn't
write down here, but which is
stop when your x-coordinate
is bigger than what you want.
Never terminates early.
Therefore we get all the
points we care about.
OK, a little bit
hand-wavy, but that
is why this structure works.
It's a very weird set up, but
linear sized, and you just
jump into the right
point in the array,
start reading, throw
away the points that
aren't in your range because
they just happen to be there.
Those would be these
points up here.
Throw away duplicates.
Just output the points in
your range and it gives you,
magically, all the points
in here by a linear scan.
I still find this so
weird, but it's true.
Truth is stranger
than fiction, I guess.
They're fun facts.
You can actually compute this
thing in the sorting bound.
So pre-processing is just sort.
I won't prove that here.
So this was two sided.
Let me briefly tell
you how to solve
three sided and four sided.
We basically already did
this one, which was--
I'll remind you
what it looks like.
So you have a binary
tree, and in each node
you store two
augmented structures.
One which can do ranged
queries like this,
and one which can do inverted
range queries like this.
This should look familiar.
And so you do a search on--
let's say we want
to do this thing.
So we have x1, x2, y2.
You search for x1,
you search for x2.
You find the LCA and then in
this subtree, you do a search.
In this subtree, you already
know that you're less than x2,
and so you do the x1,
y2 search in this node.
And then in the right subtree,
you do the x2, y2 search.
You take the union of those two
results and that is this query.
That's how we did it before.
No difficulty here.
And the point is,
you can build this,
put it in a Van
Emde Boas layout.
You do this search,
you do this search,
you find the LCA in
log base B of N--
to check that everything
works, cache obviously.
Then these structures are just
structures which we already
built, and so yes,
we lose a lag factor
because every point appears
in log data structures,
but that's it.
Everything else works the same.
So we get N log N
space log base B of N
plus output over B query.
Because now we just have to
do two queries instead of one.
We don't there's a log factor.
That's the trick we did
before OK, that was easy.
One more.
So that was three sided.
Next is four sided.
Four sided, of course, we could
do exactly the same thing.
Lose another log
factor in space.
Maintain log base B of N plus
output over B query time.
But I want to do
slightly better and this
is a trick we could have done
in internal memory as well.
But I have two minutes
to show it to you.
So here's a bonus.
Didn't have to do this in
external memory context,
but we can.
Four sided.
So we're going to do
the same thing, but not
on a binary tree.
Take this binary tree, this
is sorted by x, I suppose.
This is key on x.
Instead of making it binary,
make it root log [? N ary. ?]
So imagine taking
the binary tree,
taking little chunks, which
have size square root log
N. Its capital N. And
imagine contracting
those chunks into single nodes.
So we have a single note
which has square root
log N. Children [INAUDIBLE]
has square root log N children.
This is all static.
And so on.
Otherwise, the same.
The augmentation is going to
be a little bit different.
If we look at a
node, we're going
to store the same
things we had before,
which was this kind of query,
and this kind of query.
We're going to store
a little bit more.
Namely, for any
interval of children,
like here you have some start
child and some end child.
I want to store for all the
points that are down there.
For this thing, store a
regular binary search tree
on y for those points.
Why?
Because if we do a search--
OK, same deal-- we
find the LCA of x1, x1?
I don't know.
Let's say it's on x.
We'll have to do it
again on y whatever.
So here's the LCA.
Let's say there's
a lot of children.
OK, maybe here is
x1 and here is x2.
So in this subtree, we do this--
sorry, we do this
range query because we
want to go from x1 to infinity.
Over in this subtree, we
want to do this range query
because we want to go from
negative infinity to x2.
But then there's all
this stuff in the middle.
I don't want to have to do a
query for every single tree.
Instead, I have this
augmentation that
says for this interval,
here are all the points
sorted by x-coordinate.
I guess we're doing it this way.
Fine, so then it
is a range query.
I want to know what
are all the points.
Whoa, this is confusing.
I feel like I've
missed something here.
No, this on y.
Sorry.
These points I've
got sorted by y.
So I should draw
it the other way.
These points we already know
are in-between x1 and x2 in x.
We've already solved
the x problem here.
So now I just need to restrict
to the y range from y1 to y2.
In these trees, these
already match in x.
I just need to make
sure they match in y.
So I do a regular 1D range tree.
I search for y1,
I search for y2,
take all the points in between.
This is cheap if I just have a
regular old binary search tree.
Now, this thing has linear size.
This thing has-- sorry,
I think I actually need--
I should have a three
sided range query.
Thanks.
These should be three
sided because here I
know that I've got the
right side covered already
in this tree, I've got the
left side covered already
in this tree, but I still need
the remaining three sides.
In here, I only
need these two sides
because I've already
got x1 and x2 covered.
OK, so this is cheap.
I only need a linear
space data structure.
This thing is not so cheap.
I'm using the previous
data structure.
This thing, which
has N log N size,
these are three
sided range queries.
Sorry for drawing it wrong.
So I need two three
sided structures.
Then I need actually
a whole bunch
of these structures because
this was for every interval.
But conveniently, they're
only log N intervals
because there's
root log N children.
So root log N squared is
log N. So there's root N,
but then we need log N of them.
And so that's why these
things balance out.
See?
So normally, this would be N log
squared N because every point
would appear in log N trees.
But now the height
of my tree is merely
log N over log log
N with a factor
2 out here because I
have a square root here.
OK, so the tree has height
log N over log log N.
So each point only appears
in log N over log log N
structures.
Each of them needs a
structure size N log N.
So we end up with N log
squared N over log log N space.
Kind of crazy, but
this is how you
get that last little bit of
log log N space improvement
by contracting nodes,
doing a simpler data
structure for these
middle children,
and just focusing on--
The left child and the right
child you have to do one three
sided call, but
then the middle is
a very simple two sided call.
It's just a 1D structure
and so it's really cheap.
That's it.